I watched a lot of ancient aliens so
they'll always have an explanation man
with the air George's is a podcast a
long time ago I love that guy dude it's
my favorite dude on that show man he's
good dude I don't necessarily agree with
everything they say not everything but
that's Thursday coming there's merit to
some of it man there's a show you watch
with your boys and like one o'clock in
the morning you get baked and everybody
laughs you ever watched the Vice version
we're like Action Bronson like [ __ ]
nonsense but it's if you're high it's
[ __ ] fun to watch he came on the
podcast I never seen a dude smoke more
weed in my life he smoked by himself at
least six blunts during the podcast Wow
that dude abs so hard man I don't think
the weed really [ __ ] with him anymore
man I can think it takes that much weed
he just kept paranoid just watch him I'm
like oh I mean I smoked a little bit
with him but I mean I got to keep the
ship on the water let me keep my hands
on the wheel sir
like he just kept going but we took a
photo of the ashtray after was over was
preposterous I was like look at that
that's one show that's usually he's a
crazy guy man
fun dude though no he's a good guy I
love that [ __ ] that's delicious
good show you know that's a great show
you you know without Alchemist is a good
friend of mine I've known him since he
was young so they're good buddies I've
met him upon out what a few times he's a
really fun guy man
it's a unique idea for a show because
you know Action Bronson used to be a
chef
yeah yeah so seeing him like interact
with food and sheds like he really knows
about food it really understands for you
I think you should have a cooking show
we actually you know can whip up some
[ __ ] mean food Yeah right like we
like now that Bourdain is gone like we
need more of those kind of shows that
explore food and Bourdain show changed
the way I feel about food I used to
think of food as just something that
tastes really good I didn't think of it
as an art form and then I watched his
show and you know the reverence that he
had for chefs and for the creation of
food and made me realize like oh this is
an art form that I was ignorant of I
didn't think of it
the right way on all levels not just
like the high chef's level he brings it
to the like the home front where it's
like evening is local yeah I was making
sandwiches yeah no you're right man like
an unstraight food level he loves Tony
loved street tacos and [ __ ] he would go
everywhere in by Street food I mean
honestly when you're cooking you feel
like that don't know you cuz you cuz now
I see you cooking all the time whenever
you're posting it should never invite me
over to have someone else was gonna set
it up here I was gonna set a thing up
here but they can never figure out how
to get ventilation you know we have a
grill back there that's never been used
it's just sitting back there looking at
me he's taking a steak he's drinking one
I wonder why see this is how House Tony
his show is like they let him wear a
shirt that you can't wear so they had a
blowout a shirt that's such a Stoney
thing okay man you can't wear that shirt
yo I got it all that's it this is what
I'm wearing so do what you got to do